Hey guys,
You know, in entertainment,
unbelievers usually show Christian men as
a weird cult. Weird, spineless weak men.
It cannot be further than the truth.
Christian men are some of the most strongest
men that you will ever find in this world.
Especially mature Christians.
Why?
Because they have an edge on unbelievers.
The natural person with only their soul level.
What is that edge?
It is God's spirit in them.
God is in their corner.
[2 Timothy 1:7]
[1 Corinthians 16:13]
And that is why I have this
Christian merch on today.
Man up.
In the biblical sense of what it means to man up.
It says act like men.
And then be strong.
Now, this is not that kind of strength where you
try to persuade yourself that you are powerful.
Oh, I'm a strong man.
You puff yourself up in your arrogance.
On your soul level.
That's what unbelievers do.
No.
The strength I'm talking about is inner
strength that comes from God Himself.
Through His power.
It's not a self-confidence thing.
It is a God-confidence thing.
I'll talk about this a little bit more later on.
I want to make this video very interesting and
entertaining in showing you the top fiercest
and strongest warriors of the Bible.
You know, when you watch movies and you see
one guy taking on three or four you think,
wow, that guy is pretty good.
And when they bring out movies
with great warriors like the
movie 300, that's a good example.
You think, wow, these men were great.
They were fearless, strong.
The men I'm talking about in
the Bible are a lot stronger.
Those men, of the 300, they don't even come close
to the top seven strongest warriors of the Bible.
Let me tell you some war stories.
Let's start with the first one.
Number seven.
Jonathan and his armor-bearer.
[1 Samuel 14:13]
Two guys against many, and
they defeat 20 in the first go.
That's something special.
Number six.
Benaiah.
[2 Samuel 23:20]
What are these two ariels of Moab?
They are famous and fierce warriors.
The King James (version) says:
Now that's interesting, isn't it?
Were they some sort of Nephilim?
Half breeds, you know, half-human, half-demon?
Well, we don't know.
But it goes on and it says this.
[2 Samuel 23:21]
Now this is interesting.
We see that there are ranks between the warriors.
And we see that there are the top 30.
These guys were impressive.
But then, there are the top three.
Who are these three mighty warriors?
Well, let's take a look.
Number five: Josheb Basshebeth.
[2 Samuel 23:8]
Wow.
800 men at one time.
This was a great warrior.
Number four: Eleazar.
Which is basically the next verse.
[2 Samuel 23:9]
Wow, this is amazing.
Israel withdrew but this guy...he just
went and he just continued to fight.
And he beat them.
I don't even know how many men he had to
kill but just imagine this for a second.
What a powerful man, slaying so many
that he could not let go of his sword.
Wow.
Number three: Shamgar
[Judges 3:31]
That's it.
That's the only sentence we get about Shamgar.
We don't get anything else.
That's all we know about him and that's why a
lot of people miss this information about Shamgar.
If you talk to a lot of Christians today,
you ask them, hey who is Shamgar in the Bible?
A lot of people will say, well, I don't know.
Shamgar was one of the great judges who
took over after Ehud, another judge,
who led the nation of Israel.
He was great.
He didn't just kill 10 or 20 people but 600.
With an oxgoad.
He was a great warrior and that is why we are
including him in our first game called Judges TD.
You can get more information about it
in the video description down below.
Number two: Samson.
Samson was unbelievably strong.
I mean, who does not know about Samson, right?
Most of us grew up with stories about Samson.
He was ...he was something else.
He killed a lion with his bare hands.
[Judges 14:5]
[Judges 15:15]
[Judges 14:19]
[Judges 16:3]
Man, I just get tired of climbing a big hill and
running a little bit, but Samson, he broke off
these huge... I mean, big iron gates.
And he walked with them 30 miles.
And then after that, he climbed the
hill to the top with it as well.
It's unbelievable.
Why was he so strong?
Because he just believed in his own power?
No, he was strong because of God.
[Judges 14:5-6]
Wow,
It's a jaw-drop moment, right?
Imagine if you see that
happening right in front of you.
It's unbelievable.
Samson was a great warrior, and that is why
we are also going to include him in our game.
Actually let's make it interesting.
Let me show you a sneak peek of
Samson in the game Judges TD.
Pretty cool, isn't it?
Alright, let's continue.
Number one is David.
By now, most of you know about David, right?
You've probably already heard about the
stories about David, this warrior, fearless,
who came and slayed Goliath the giant.
A lot of men were cowering.
I can just imagine how I would feel standing
there looking at Goliath and thinking, hmm,
I don't know.
But here David goes.
And is there's something different about David.
He also led the nation of Israel to victory.
Many victories over the Philistines.
Ammonites.
Moabites.
And many others.
Why was David so special?
A man that is great?
There was something different about David.
What was it?
I mean, the Bible says:
[1 Samuel 18:14]
You see, that is the key.
He acted wisely.
And God was with him.
You see, he knew that he is
a lot stronger with God at his side.
Not trying to do things on his own,
but living righteously, seeking the heart of God.
That is God-confidence, not self-confidence.
And that is why we read:
[Acts 13:22]
Who will do all My will.
Did you get that?
Wow.
Imagine God says this about you.
That you are a man after God's own heart.
Do you want him to say that?
Well, then let me ask you.
Do you do His will?
Do you walk within His
plan and purpose for your life, like David did?
You cannot just be a hearer
of His Word, and not a doer.
[James 1:22-25]
This is what it means to be
a man of God's own heart.
This is how you can be a strong warrior
through Christ, that gives you strength.
And make no mistake, you are already in
the battle, whether you like it or not.
We are in a spiritual battle and you need
to put on the armor of God and fight.
[Ephesians 6:11]
[Ephesians 6:12]
There are far too many fat and
lazy Christian men in the world.
They go to church.
They go to Bible studies.
They get all the spiritual food, week in,
week out, and they do nothing with it.
So they get spiritually fat and lazy.
What do you do for God?
Have you been looking at the world recently?
Look at the world, how evil is taking over,
because so many Christian men are doing nothing.
If you see wrong, unrighteousness in the world
as a true reborn Christian, a man of
the living God, you need to expose it,
because that's what light does.
Light exposes that which is in darkness.
[Ephesians 5:11]
And here it comes, so listen closely.
Now, to all you men who think you're
Christians and you're not spiritually reborn.
It is very dangerous if you go in the name of
God and you try to expose and just judge people
left and right through your fleshly nature.
Because you will do a lot more harm than good.
But if God leads you to act in the
Spirit, then you need to obey Him.
The armor of God is not there for you
so that you can sit on the sidelines and do
nothing and just comment here from your phone.
You know, I see a lot of Christians
comment on ministries and they complain.
They say, oh, what about this.
Why are you doing this and well
what are you doing for the kingdom?
Evil is taking over in certain areas
causing suffering that is unnecessary, because
we are supposed to be the light in the world,
to help the poor, to help the weak.
But a lot of Christian men are doing nothing.
You are called to be the light of the world.
And to go and make disciples of all people.
[Matthew 28:19]
There is a battle going on for souls and you see,
if you truly are a reborn Christian, then you love
God with your whole heart and soul and if you do
really love Him, you will also love other people.
Because His love in you - you can't stop it.
You have that love.
That agape, unconditional
love for other people as well.
You hate their sin but you love
people and you want them to be saved.
How can you keep the message
of the Gospel to yourself?
That is selfish.
If you truly love other people then you would
not want them to go to hell for all eternity.
To lose their souls for all eternity.
You see, our real battle is not physical.
It is spiritual, against the devil and his demons.
[1 Peter 5:8]
In the Old Testament, in the time of the
Israelites, they had to defend their own
nation to defend the birth of the Messiah.
You see, the devil and his demons were using
other nations to try and stop the birth of the
Messiah, who is Jesus Christ, who would come,
was prophesized to come, not just to save the
nation of Israel, but to save the whole world.
And you see, He did come.
He already died for
our sins on the cross.
So that we might be free.
He is already victorious and we are
victorious through Jesus Christ.
[1Corinthians 15:57]
[Romans 8:37]
You see, the devil already
knows that he's been defeated.
Now, he's just angry.
That's why he's walking around like a roaring
lion, looking at someone who he can devour.
He's trying to drag as many
humans with him into hell.
God saved you and now with the time that He
has still given you, that you have left here
on this temporary world, you need to use to
shine your light so that you can save others.
And you need to use the spiritual
weapons that He gave you.
[2 Corinthians 10:3-5]
Now, put on the armor of God.
And use it wisely to fight through the Spirit.
Do not be distracted by temporary earthly
things that do not even matter when we look
at the eternal things, the things above.
You know, a lot of Christians spend their
time on things that do not matter.
And the devil is laughing because
he is distracting you.
Think, right now,
how many people that you know are still unsaved?
And maybe for some of you, the things that you
think about is... oh, this person needs
to need to do this and this.... car needs
to go.... and he needs to go to that
person and do those earthly things.
What about spiritual things?
What about their souls?
Pray about them... for them ... and
let God lead you to save their souls.
[1 Corinthians 9:19]
Do you understand what he's saying here?
He is connecting with people on their level, so
that he can share the gospel to them effectively.
But a lot of you Christians out there are
arrogant.
You don't want to change to share the gospel.
I'm not saying that we have
to compromise the Word of God.
I'm saying we have to preach it in
truth - in love - but there are ways
that you can do it to different types
of people to share it more effectively.
[1 Corinthians 9:22]
Some of you out there are too stubborn.
Stuck in your old ways, your comfort zone.
And because you are so stuck and not willing to
change and to connect with people on their level,
they are not hearing the Gospel from you.
People around you cannot find God
because you are not even trying to
connect with them at their level.
You judge in anger instead of
sharing the gospel in truth and love.
A lot of people do not like the truth,
especially when we talk about sins and
hell and, you know, it depends on what
the Holy Spirit leads us to talk about.
People feel guilty.
They don't want their darkness to be exposed.
But that is what the Gospel does.
The truth of the Gospel.
And it doesn't mean that you shouldn't share the
Gospel because now people feel uncomfortable.
You should share it but there is a way
to share it effectively in love where
they know this person is sharing this with me
because they actually really do care about me.
They love me.
They don't want me to be lost.
So is what they are saying actually true?
You see, that's where the Gospel is powerful.
When you share it through the Spirit.
Through truth and through love.
Those of you who are still
stubborn in your old ways,
You might not even realize this, but
you're doing it through your flesh.
You're not doing it through the Spirit.
What are you doing?
Your weapons are supposed to
be the gifts of the Spirit.
[Galatians 5:22]
Now, to understand this more, please
watch this series that I covered on
the fruit of the Spirit, and I'll see you there.
And before you go, always remember, God loves you.
And I love you, too.
Bye.